good morning Hank it's Tuesday thank you
for my birthday present Hank nerdfighter
I got me 170 4.3 llamas through heifer
org that will go to families in need
I'm a little concerned about the family
that's gonna get 2.3 llamas but I think
everyone else is gonna be delighted
okay so I've promised for weeks that I
would fly in a helicopter with Bill
Gates and now I shall I was pretty
scared flying in a helicopter for the
first time this is my last message I
love my family but it turned out to be
kind of Awesome for one thing we didn't
crash but also up there on our way to
visit farmers working with the World
Food Program I could see families
tilling individual plots of land and
that was kind of a cool entree into
thinking about agricultural economics
now I know that this stuff is
complicated and some people find it kind
of boring but you know what's not boring
food delicious food so it's really
important to think about like maize
production per hectacre because someday
that corn will turn into the corn syrup
in your Pizza Hut pizza dough with this
Pizza Hut pizza dough really contain
corn syrup it does pickled Rotovirus
that is disgusting by the way I'm trying
out this new thing where instead of
cursing I named a way of cooking food in
a disease I dislike you know like baked
malaria or steamed Ebola anyway Hank I
live in Indiana where the state motto is
all corn all the time occasionally
soybeans and our corn plants are like
taller than me and they're extremely
productive they produce six thousand
kilograms per hectacre in Ethiopia they
get around 2,000 kilograms for
cultivated hectacre and that's with
dramatic improvements in the last twenty
years so why are our field so much more
productive than their fields well I
don't know much about agriculture but
according to people who do it has a lot
to do with good seed and fertilizer so
as these farmers explain to us you can
grow maize with seeds from last year's
harvest and no fertilizer but it ends up
producing a lot less corn per hectacre
like it's usually about waist-high
to get the taller than me american like
corn which i did see some of in ethiopia
you need good seed and good fertilizer
which costs money
okay these are made-up numbers but let's
say that with bad seed and no fertilizer
you'll make $500 per harvest and with
good seed and fertilizer you'll make a
thousand now seed and fertilizer cost a
hundred dollars so this is a no-brainer
right definitely see definitely
fertilizer except last year you only
made $500 so you don't have that $100
because you spent all of your money on
like
Baker era Doctor Who DVDs and also like
food and medicine no problem right
because you can just go to the bank and
explain to them that if they won't you
$100 you're going to make five hundred
extra dollars so won't have a problem
paying them back yeah
but one it's not like that Bank has a
diversified portfolio of loans I mean in
a country where almost everyone is a
farmer almost all loans are farming
loans so if there's some bug that eats a
lot of the corn or it doesn't rain that
year no one can pay back their loans
which can cause the banks to go under
which makes them hesitant to make loans
also too if everybody gets alone and
everybody gets good seed that harvest go
way up and the price of maize will
plummet there will be too much maize in
the marketplace you don't have the
resources to store your maize until
prices go up so you won't make a
thousand dollars in the end now there
are tons of other problems and
complexities here but in general the
point I'm trying to make is that food is
a weird commodity like say you make too
many Cabbage Patch dolls and they're
like clogging the aisles of toy stores
then you can just stop making Cabbage
Patch dolls but if you do that with food
eventually people are going to need food
and not in the way that they need
Cabbage Patch dolls so you have this
vicious cycle you could produce more
food with capital intensive products
like seed and fertilizer but you can't
get the capital to use them and if you
did somehow increase production the
price might drop so much that it
wouldn't be worth it at least not in the
short run and there's also a vicious
circle on the buyer side buyers are
afraid that farmers won't be able to
fulfill their contracts so they don't
give them big contracts and don't allow
them the opportunity to become large
suppliers so let's say you somehow break
those vicious cycles well lots of good
things start to happen like in China
rice yields quadrupled between 1960 and
1990 and then BOOM and in Brazil
agricultural yield tripled between 1970
and 2005 here's what poverty rates in
Brazil and China look like over the last
40 years now I don't want to conflate
correlation and causation but fried
meningitis that is some nice-looking
correlation so how do we break those
vicious cycles well in Ethiopia there's
a fascinating project with the World
Food Program whereby farmers are
guaranteed a fair price for however much
corn they can produce and then the
surplus goes to food aid now
traditionally in Ethiopia most food aid
comes from the United States now almost
half of Ethiopia's food aid comes from
within Ethiopia which makes it
cheaper and more efficient and also it
increases yields so the World Food
Programme offers these farmers a
contract that allows them to go and get
a loan for good seed and fertilizer
because you know the UN is generally
good for its debt yields increase
there's more food and there is less
malnutrition and then the hope is that
over time if these higher yields become
sustainable that Ethiopia will see the
kind of growth in poverty reduction that
we've seen in like China and Brazil in
India from what I can tell this program
seems to be working but it is extremely
complicated like I met this woman who
used to be a recipient of food aid
imported from the US but now is a
producer of food aid and that is awesome
after I talked to her I was feeling very
happy but then when Bill Gates and Sue
Desmond Helmand dug deeper it became
clear that she doesn't get to keep any
of the money from her land it all goes
to her husband now the increased yield
and increased family income is
definitely good but another mission of
the project to help empower women
farmers and let them keep the proceeds
of their work isn't as effective on the
other hand she is a founding member of
this farmers cooperative which gives her
power within her family similarly I
talked for a while to these women whose
job it was to sort through the corn by
hand to pull out anything other than
corn kernels so that it would pass WFP
standards for food purity I was told
that they were also farmers who did this
for extra income but the women told me
that they weren't farmers and that this
was their primary work and that it was
exhausting and difficult but that the
money was pretty good I don't know what
good money was for them but the men
loading these bags of maize onto trucks
made about five dollars a day so it's
easy enough to note the privilege of my
particular life with its helicopter
rides and video blogging what's much
harder is to think about how each of us
can contribute toward making a world in
which more people can need healthy and
productive lives the truth about that is
complicated and messy and any easy
narratives you may hear are in my
opinion overly simplistic there is no
magic bullet when it comes to poverty it
is a tangled and many tentacled beast
like to return to my birthday Lamas for
a moment tank the actual sourcing and
distribution of those Lamas will be
tremendously challenging and complicated
the work doesn't end when the money gets
raised it begins and no program works
perfectly or succeeds all the time I
think I think the WFP project is really
interesting and I think that it can help
but I might be wrong and I've been wrong
before and there are also other things
that would help like for instance it
would help if the Ethiopian government
it's ban on corn exports so there's no
question that agricultural yields have
been rising over the last ten years in
Ethiopia and that is very encouraging
but still 44% of Ethiopian children are
stunted due to malnutrition that is
unacceptable and it's also unnecessary
if Ethiopia is cultivated land produced
as many calories per hectacre as China's
or Brazil's
no Ethiopian would have to starve so I
know that increasing like calories per
cultivated hectacre isn't the sexiest
problem the world is facing but it is
one of the most important nerdfighteria
thank you again for my birthday Lamas
they just made me so happy hank dftba I
will see you on Friday